early it was a stunning revelation that
might have cost children their lives of
course it was not the right decision it
was the wrong decision
the texas director of public safety
explained that while a gunman was
shooting children inside rob elementary
school police waited outside for 78
minutes much longer than authorities had
said earlier saying police thought the
gunman was barricaded alone and no
longer a threat to children he choked up
forget how i'm doing what about the
parents
children
governor greg abbott and local residents
reacted with fury i was misled
i am livid
about what happened like this is in the
back on the back of the cop car to
protect and serve protect who
why didn't they protect kids
as those shocking revelations came out
the gunman's mother made a humble plea
i think
i have no words i have no words to say
because i don't know what he was
thinking
across the state of texas in houston the
national rifle association held its
first convention in three years despite
the deaths of 21 people in uvalde
with former president donald trump his
keynote speaker still an unapologetic
supporter of gun rights as always in the
wake of these tragedies the various gun
control policies being pushed
by the left would have
done nothing to prevent the horror that
took place absolutely nothing
ironically due to his presence no guns
were allowed inside the gun convention
[Applause]
the crowd outside the convention is as
animated as the crowd inside there are
thousands of people out here and their
message is the nra should go away
the massive throng protested the group's
timing and goals
high profile figures addressed the
crowds inside and out we will defeat you
and we will overcome you and we will
leave you behind
democratic congresswoman sheila jackson
lee says the nra meeting is unwelcome in
her district we welcome them
as human beings and visitors
and enjoy the city but cancel your
meetings
amid the din of the crowd perhaps the
most somber demonstration was a
child-sized coffin a reminder of just
how high the stakes are in the american
gun debate
john hendren al jazeera houston